[Musik]
wir sind glücklich
zehn träumchen das was oben drauf ist
nussig schokoladig und frisch
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Ferrero Rocher Torte einfach eine Torte
die an so festlichen Tagen alle Blicke
auf sich zieht und man einfach denkt da
habe ich jetzt gerade richtig Bock drauf
ich starte jetzt direkt mit der
Zubereitung des Bodens ihr wisst ja mal
mein Rezepten findet ihr mal alle ganz
genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in der
Infobox einfach damit nicht so langatmig
wird und wird direkt starten wir müssen
zuallererst die Eier trennen also Eiweiß
von Eigelb trennen und das Eiweiß wird
dann zusammen mit Zucker einer Prise
Salz und auch gern schon Vanilleextrakt
in der Küchenmaschine zu einer
Baisermasse geschlagen
[Musik]
also wenn man es ganz genau nimmt
funktioniert am allerbesten wenn ihr
erstmal das Eiweiß mit Salz ein bisschen
schon mal schaumig schlagt und dann gebt
ihr Zucker dazu und an der Stelle gerne
auch schon Vanilleextrakt und dann wie
gesagt noch mal ein zwei Minuten lang zu
einer Baisermasse schlagen das heißt so
eine richtig schön festen Eiweißmasse
[Musik]
ist fertig richtig schön steif und jetzt
kommt hier Eigelb mit Rohrzucker also
braunen Rohrzucker der schmeckt einfach
noch mal karamelliger wird jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz in der Schüssel verrührt
und anschließend gebe ich zerlassene
Butter mit dazu die sollte nicht ganz so
heiß sein in der Mikrowelle am besten
immer mit geringer Wattzahl arbeiten
damit sie euch nicht platzt oder auch
nicht zu heiß wird
[Musik]
als nächstes heben wir die steif
geschlagene Eiweißmasse unter die
Eigelbmasse und das erstmal mit ganz
viel Liebe also ganz langsam das hat man
das Gefühl dass verbindet sich nie aber
wenn ihr immer weiter rührt und schafft
dann verbindet sich das und dann könnt
ihr schon mal die nächste Ladung nehmen
solange bis die Eiweißmasse komplett
aufgebraucht ist
[Musik]
Mehl Backkakao und Backpulver gebe ich
jetzt in meinen Sieb und dann Siebe ich
erstmal nur die Hälfte da rein können
das auch im Sieb schon mal so ein
bisschen miteinander vermengen und dann
auch wieder mit dem Teigschaber in so
schabenden Bewegungen einfach
einarbeiten und das ganze in zwei
Etappen also die Hälfte ist drin die
andere Hälfte kommt gleich rein und ganz
zum Schluss kommen noch gemahlene
Haselnusskerne mit dazu
[Musik]
so unser Teig ist jetzt fertig ich habe
jetzt hier meine 24er Springform und da
gebe ich jetzt einen Backpapier auf den
Boden und gebe den Teig rein den dann
schön glatt verstreichen und einmal ab
in den Backofen damit
[Musik]
während der Boden jetzt gerade auskühlt
mache ich weiter mit unserer leckeren
Nougatfüllung da habe ich jetzt hier
mascarpone mit Mascarpone kann man ganz
gut so weil der halt sehr neutral
schmeckt kann man ganz gut so Cremes
kreieren und hier habe ich Nuss-Nougat
der ist in der Regel schon sehr weich
sollte der hart sein es gibt auch einige
Marken da ist Nuss-Nougat relativ hart
wobei je nach Lagerung hier bei mir
gerade auch könnt ihr den so ein
bisschen in der Mikrowelle anwärmen aber
nicht zu warm zu Mascarpone geben werde
ich jetzt an der Stelle auch machen also
so für ein paar Sekunden anwärmen in der
Mikrowelle bei geringer Wattzahl und
dann zusammen mit Puderzucker und
Vanilleextrakt kurz glatt rühren
[Musik]
so Mascarpone nougat-masse ist jetzt
soweit fertig hat sich alles schön
verbunden am besten funktioniert es wenn
ihr die Mascarpone so eine halbe
Dreiviertelstunde vorher aus dem
Kühlschrank nehmen und sie nicht ganz so
kalt ist weil sonst habt ihr so
Klümpchen drin und das verbindet sich
nicht gut mit dem lauwarmen oder weichem
Nougat so ziemlich jetzt mal ganz kurz
zur Seite und jetzt hier wiederum ganz
kalt aus dem Kühlschrank einmal
Schlagsahne die wird hier steif
geschlagen und ein Tipp von mir was ich
auch gemacht habe ich habe die Schüssel
gerade ausgewaschen am Ende noch mal
kaltes Wasser reingeben und in den
Kühlschrank stellen zusammen mit dem
Schneebesen damit sich die Sahne auch
gut aufschlagen lässt
[Musik]
so zusammen habe ich noch Sahnefest
hinzugegeben damit ich einfach noch mal
eine feste Sahne habe und das rühre ich
bzw hebe ich jetzt mit ganz viel Liebe
und einem Teigschaber unter die
nougat-masse das mache ich in mehreren
Schritten in zwei bis drei Schritten und
dann ist unsere Füllung auch schon
fertig und ich kann den Boden
durchschneiden und wir können auch schon
befüllen eigentlich auch ein relativ
schnelles Rezept oder
[Musik]
so jetzt schneide ich wie gesagt einmal
den Boden in der Mitte durch Springform
entfernen natürlich auch einmal das
Backpapier wegnehmen
so und den Boden einfach nur in der
Mitte durchschneiden und dann suche ich
mir eine wunderschöne Tortenplatte aus
und kann das ganze auch schon Schichten
ich nehme jetzt hier meine tortensäge
das ist die mit der echten Säge das
heißt dadurch dass mein Boden sehr sehr
frisch ist ich weiß damals als ich die
noch nicht hatte weiß ich von den
Problemen mit der tortensäge mit Draht
und gerade bei frischen Kuchen krümelt
der extrem das Problem habt ihr hier
nicht also einmal durchschneiden und
dann Schichten
ich nehme jetzt was von der Creme zur
Seite weil ich brauche ja noch ein
bisschen was gleich für außen und wollte
auch noch so Tupfer auf die Torte machen
also Zwecke ich mir so ein bisschen was
ab damit ich mich gleich nicht Ärger und
das was dann noch übrig ist da gebe ich
dann die Hälfte einmal in den Tortenring
dann den anderen Boden drauf und dann
den Rest drauf verteilen
[Musik]
meine Torte kommt jetzt eine Stunde
kühlen wenn ihr keine Zeit habt geht
auch ein dreiviertel Stunde allerdings
bin ich immer Fan davon gerade bei
solchen Cremes dass man die fertige
Torte anschließend noch mal zwei bis
drei Stunden kühlt weil je länger ihr
sie kühlt desto schnittfester wird die
Masse aber manchmal ist man halt auch
ungeduldig so jetzt einmal mit dem
backformlöser am Rand entlang fahren
dann werde ich hier einmal den
Tortenring entfernen und dann schon mal
ich habe hier ganz viel Restcreme schon
mal die Seiten einstreichen und den Rest
der da noch übrig bleibt den gebe ich
mir in einen Spritzbeutel für die Tupfer
oben drüber
[Musik]
so restliche Creme ist jetzt im
Spritzbeutel mit einer großen Lochtülle
von ca 1 cm und jetzt gebe ich hier noch
gehackte und geröstete Haselnusskerne an
den Rand der Torte das was mir so
runterfällt lasse ich einfach wieder in
die Schüssel reinfallen und dann mache
ich einmal an den ganzen Rand die
Haselnusskerne dann wird eigentlich nur
noch dekoriert mit der restlichen Creme
und natürlich kommen dann noch Rocher
und top damit man halt auch weiß nach
was die Torte schmeckt
[Musik]
wir sind glücklich wir haben eine Rocher
Torte die sieht total perfekt aus und
ich denke dass sie auch extrem lecker
schmecken
Willen Versprechungen
Teller für dich und wenn man ihm lang
genug kühlen lässt werden die Schichten
einfach perfekt 10 von 10 auf jeden Fall
nur zehn Tipps gegeben ganz ehrlich was
heißt erzählt
so Konsistenz zehn von zehn träumchen
schmeckt richtig
ich wollte halt keine Rocher zerkleinern
zermatschen oder sonst was und reintun
irgendwie in die Schichten sondern
einfach ein Schoko Nussboden kreieren
und fertig genau nussig schokoladig und
frisch weil ich muss sagen schmeckt dir
nicht so frisch sondern eher so leckere
süße Praline aber hier hat man halt eine
frische Torte könnt ihr euch lecker
war super lecker guck mal weißt du das
jetzt machen so heute hatte ich keine
Zeit zum Mittagessen kochen wir gehen
jetzt zu deiner Mama ist nämlich auf dem
Weg zum Ruhrpark und da gebe ich dann
die Torte ab und tausche gegen lecker
gekochtes Mittagessen machen wir so okay
noch im Kühlschrank
was haben wir getauscht
Kuchen gegen
haben habe ich immer schnell mitgenommen
also Kuchen getauscht gegen essen also
viel Spaß heute nachmachen sollte das
Rezept gefallen haben dann hinterlasst
auf jeden Fall einen Kommentar unten
Däumchen nach oben
ja einfach wieder zurück in den Schrank
kein Problem also bis dann tschüss